welcome to a video on editing video
with blender we have updated blender
since the last video
to a just a point one higher we're on
now 2.90.1
not sure what the changes are but there
was a slight update so i went ahead and
applied that
so i'm going to talk about proxies this
time and basically making it so that
your
sequencer is quick and responsive
this basically allows you to actually
edit video because you may have noticed
from before that when you click around
in your in your little sequencer down
here
you have video going on up there it's
super super super slow and very it's
just barely functional
okay so i'm just going to load into new
video you can drag it in from a folder
or you can navigate up here i'm just
going to navigate
grab some one of these
there i am doing something all right
bring this back to the beginning
and hit page up set this to the end
you still got to do your settings as
usual i'll do those real quick
ffmpeg over here drop down
coding change it to audio i'm just doing
this out of habit something you should
get used to anytime you start doing a
new video
is make sure that these are all set go
hit save
we'll just call this a demo proxy
so just in case i need to reopen it or
it crashes or whatever so that's the
first thing you should do
always even though this is about proxies
it's still about setting up your project
so you can actually work it so
of course set up your output set up your
settings hit save so the first thing i
do once i get
all my video clips drug in and i want to
start editing them because
you know once you start clicking around
and hitting play and going through it
it's super laggy
click over here gotta wait a few seconds
and the further you get into your
project
and the more stuff you start editing the
laggier
it gets so after a while it just becomes
completely unbearable
so what you can do is you can proxy
these clips and what proxy in the clips
does
is it breaks it up into smaller files so
that when you're navigating through in
the sequencer
it can display smaller files up here for
you to flip through
and it basically becomes a lot more
responsive a lot
nicer to work with and when you still do
your final render it's still based off
your render dimensions up here so it
doesn't reduce the quality of your
rendering your rendering is the same
it just makes it so it's faster to edit
but you have a lower resolution
viewport here which is generally not too
big of a deal because it's just
editing purposes only so all you do is
you click on the clip
and then over here you go to proxy and
cache
and make sure this is to per strip
and then you want to check this proxy
and time code down here
and if these carrots are pointing to the
side you need to click them and drop it
down so you can see
and i generally put it on 25 because 25
is small enough that it's pretty fast
in about any case but if you've got a
pretty fast hard drive you can
you can make slower ones and now you can
build these for several
sizes at a time to save space on my hard
drive i'm only going to build the 25
ones in this case but if you want to
build several of them you can
basically where that comes into play is
later once you've built them
you can go up here to where you're on
your preview
and click this little right arrow that's
next to the zoom thing
it's very tiny you can barely see it but
you got to click it and this whole
active tool thing appears so i'm going
to go ahead and build this clip
so i've got my video clicked and
highlighted
i've got 25 percent clicked over here on
this proxy and cache per strip
i'm not going to mess with strip cache
there it's going to leave it all default
so once you hit let's see here
rebuild proxy and time code indices it
will start
and i'll show you a little progress bar
and down at the bottom right how far
along it is
you gotta wait the bigger project is the
more things that's building
the longer it will take okay that has
now completed it went through and built
all the proxies now we can go up here to
where our view is
and actually got to go down to this view
tab i was on tool before so i actually
got to go to view
and you see here under view settings
there is some options here you can see
proxy render size as one of them so you
change this drop down
down to the 25 and you see that the
quality reduces here but now
when i click through this it's super
snappy it's instant and the same with
playback if i hit play on this
it doesn't lag it's just super fast so
that's
this actually makes it very usable and
there is a technical reason for this
and i'm going to kind of wing this but
just to give you a feeling of why these
proxies matter
so when you load in a big video clip and
you want to go to a certain section of
it
there's this huge chunk of memory you
have to find a certain section and or
the computer does
and that just takes a whole lot of
memory it takes a whole lot of caching a
lot of things run through the the cpu
cache and it just has to do so much work
to work with that giant piece of memory
and get to a certain index of it but
once you do these proxies
it's now a bunch of small jpegs which
are they're each individual piece of
memory
and they can load each individually
super quick rather than having to load
the entire clip of video and then
navigate it's just
load a tiny image and that's it so that
doesn't necessarily need to make sense
and i'm
sort of sort of uh guessing and assuming
a lot of things in that explanation but
that is basically
my understanding of why proxies make it
so much faster i don't really mess with
any of
these other settings there's a whole
bunch of other stuff but only the stuff
i've talked about
is all that i ever do when i do this and
that's all it takes to make it snappy
and that's you know that's the goal no
need to mess with additional settings
so another thing that people are
probably going to ask is you know you
bring in multiple clips
or you've already done some cuts so let
me bring in another clip here
and i just want to talk quickly about
how to do a multiple
once you drag it in so if you have
multiple clips
you can go over here you know you select
one of them you select a clip select the
other one by holding shift you got both
of them selected now you can do
per project and you can build
the entire thing so in this case if i
want to build them both now when i hit
rebuild
it's going to build them all i guess per
strip if you have them selected should
rebuild them all
as long as i have multiple selected or i
can you know you can go through one by
one and do them but if you have multi
selected it should
do per strip but if you just want to do
your whole project you can hit project
and rebuild your whole project at once
and that will do it so hope that helps
with your editing and making it faster
and making it you know all the cutting
and everything else is still the same
just makes it snappy
and once again it doesn't affect the
final render resolution
so when you go up to render render
animation and
get it in your output directory that
quality is still going to be the same
so very important super nice definitely
something you want to do
right away after getting your clips in
it's worth the time of building the
proxies because it ends up
saving you so much more time and also so
much frustration
because one of the most frustrating
things about video editing
is that whole lag time in your sequencer
and in your edits and this just
is a solution so most video editors do
have this sort of thing
well that's it for this video let me
know if you have any questions see in
the next one
[Music]
you